yeah so bad how's it going red let his
printer back as you can see I'm in Italy
and gonna stay here a few days but I
wanted to make a video anyway you bro
sent me a game called big rigs which I
thought first was a porno but apparent
it's a game it's famous for being the
best game ever made and my best game I
mean of course the shittiest game ever
made let's play big rigs over the road
racing what do we got mega own Thunder
bull sunrise version 12 the mega mega 1
oh that's it how does make out the
loading screen is takes forever sly how
much what do you need to load honestly
come on
oh why is okay um I don't know how to
accelerate oh good that's what I wanted
to do holy [ __ ] it's fast as hell I
guess we're going backwards said
20 seconds and we're already broke the
game
can I go oh what that where you go okay
I think this is a finished product
pretty much I don't know where I'm going
adventure somewhere I think we're going
back yeah we are
yes male leg take a little shortcut
doesn't matter
there we are finished male ledge yeah
how's the checkpoint god damn it
can I go here oh I go through it yes of
course this aims pretty realistic
let's jump off the cliff hell yeah
mother okay nailed it nailed it market
old games feel like this and this is
better than all the sonic racing games
this is like when I play horror games I
just hugged the balls let's block this
[ __ ] he just stopped what am i doing I
gotta win come on
my sad lamppost where did he go he just
became invisible oh of course
why would you go on the bench when you
can go through the bridge why would you
go around the fountain when you can
watch what you can go through it it's so
intense
oh no he's winning better use my special
move wall riding there's just no way I
can go above 80 finished good enough for
me
just a small time night ride let's go
for a night ride with our truck all
right here we go we're racing against
the douche bag again gonna use a u-turn
you tactic
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
why is wet what is happening whoa
the reverse the reverse man it's so fast
it's so fast happening what is happening
god forget me Oh Oh God I I definitely
and we're back let's let's restart the
race ah so funny since I'm obviously way
faster reverse I'm just gonna go reverse
instantaneously stop when you let go
everybody ha noob I'm faster oh god oh
god no God no God [ __ ] I did it again I
did it again that might the reverse
whoever coded the reverse is a [ __ ]
genius initiate time warp zone space the
final frontier
I keep accelerating look at this [ __ ]
I'm going - for five thousand that's
pretty fast
that's pretty [ __ ] fast we're going -
sixty I'm just waiting for like a black
hole - it create or some [ __ ] like that
yeah this is so bad oh my god
and we're back let's ride towards the
sunset I mean the moonlight all the maps
looks identical if I didn't know any
better I'd say they just [ __ ] use the
same map but change the lightning a
little bit alright works the same let's
go on the bridge oh wait nevermind hey
I'm back what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah [ __ ] you town you can't tell me
what is that a person they just put one
guy there this is a company that pays
attention to detail yeah just put one
[ __ ] guy is that a car is that a car
that's supposed to be a car isn't it
god damn this game is beautiful I need
to catch up with him better use my super
power to reverse yes oh god no no oh yes
I'm waiting I think what what happened
yes catch em good gotta catch up I press
that was big riggs [ __ ] hilarious
I hope you guys enjoyed watching leave a
like if you did it's ask ina Cobra today
I see Russ in the next one
stay awesome love you